the tiny dark bottles in these labs are
filled with mysterious potions
they hold the flavors that millions of
people taste and smell every day when
you think of snacking so maybe potato
chips or cereal bars or something like
that you know do you think of a flavor
they all contain flavor Jesse Wolfe is
the vice president of flavors at
international flavors and fragrances or
iff the publicly traded company makes a
lot of what we put in our mouths tastes
really good so when I walk into the
supermarket how many products on the
shelves have IFF flavors in them well I
don't know how many have iff flavors in
general in the supermarket about 90% of
the products do contain some type of
flavor flavor is much more than just
what our tongue senses it's also about
what our nose smells they smell amazing
and all IFF flavors start in a kitchen
lab with aromas so here we start with
some fresh oranges this is the first
step in the IFF process capturing the
scent so then this turns on creates a
vacuum gathers the scent molecules and
then what it's pulling the aromas into
the sand like material and it's
capturing all of those volatile those
aromas we take that sand and then we
analyze it to find out what the oranges
Amanah a computer breaks down the aromas
into a kind of molecular map or
fingerprint and then iff flavors use
these fingerprints as a recipe to create
scientifically enhanced flavors flavors
like the ones iff creates are a critical
part of the food industry they're more
reliable and cost-effective than using
the real thing for example oranges it
helps to have some of the real juice but
if the juice is not of the quality that
you want and in that flavor will give
you more consistency and a better
overall flavor a food company might use
an iff flavor to make sure every pint of
orange sherbert tastes exactly the same
delicious every time the idea then is
that the sherbert with the IFF flavor is
actually tastier than just one without
the additional flavors that's what we're
hoping you're gonna see okay let's see
if you can tell the difference very
oranjee it's great huh you see a bump in
the orange in that one or you're not
sure yet thank I do it again yes this
one's more orange that one's a little
more bland pick the right one
IFS is tight-lipped about exactly which
products they put their mark on but they
work with all the major food companies a
lot of secrecy around who's doing what
with whom and is that because they don't
want anyone else to get their flavors
once we create a signature for somebody
they don't want us creating something
similar for somebody else